I tell people where you fly and all that
great stuff about the equipment that
you've got sure well good afternoon we
fly in the Bay Area airport called San
Carlo so we fly to four different points
Santa Barbara Hawthorne which is the
private airport right next to LAX and
then we fly to burbank and then also
truckee tahoe so it's it's very simple
you gave the sales pitch pim 460 as low
as 1600 a month you can fly as much as
you want between those those points Jeff
tell us about the backers of the airline
and how this came to be well I think you
know with my background predominantly in
the aviation the airline business and
then I also ran a membership club you
know when the founder initially thought
of this I kind of kicked myself thinking
I should have been the one de to think
of it but he had the vision he had a
sound vision and we'd get to grow from
there but wait wait I early right yep
that's wait I early and it was simply
about a matter of convenience both
economic convenience but also
convenience and low stress travel and as
you might suspect between those points i
just mentioned there is a lot of travel
within a particular month when in a
particular year and we've we've created
a non-stress travel experience we have
private concierge is in the airports we
service only into private terminals so
you can arrive 15 minutes prior to your
departure time concierge typically knows
you by name and vice versa the crew that
two pilots help you load the luggage and
off you go and you know from a matter of
convenience you're probably saving
anywhere from two to three hours per
one-way trip and so we're very much
focused on those people and that's a lot
of us that just simply value our time
well jeffa described the the airplane
aircraft equipment it's a swiss-made the
Pilatus pc-12 correct it's a turboprop
aircraft it's fast it's safe it's
reliable it's quiet our interior seating
is executive seating we have
seven seats the front for actually face
each other and what's very interesting
about this business model is that sense
of community that comes with being in a
club for instance I happen to be one of
those Wi-Fi guys and when you pose that
question to our current membership of
which we now have over 600 members most
of them say no we don't want the Wi-Fi
they want that interaction with other
members our booking our resume how you
make a reservations it's a mobile
application you can book a reservation
within 30 seconds you can opt in to
allow other passengers members to see
you and when you're flying and so they
get to interact with each other and
that's probably one of the more yes sir
where where do you want to fly next
where would you like to expand either
you got plans for Las Vegas we do have
we're awaiting government approval to
fly to Las Vegas our primary focus is in
the southwest but even more so still
within California there's a lot of
routes it's obviously not an infinite
number but we're in the midst of we've
developed our five-year plan and we're
now going through the process of decide
on what that fleet looks like and
actually start the process to obtain
that additional Eric